[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente y este es nuestro recorrido
de hoy vamos a méjico con andrés manuel
lópez obrador que se dio un baño de
masas en plena pandemia y en medio de la
preocupación por la variante omicron que
ya está en nuestro continente el
presidente celebró el tercer aniversario
de su llegada al poder en el zócalo
capitalino les contamos sus logros y sus
deudas y visitamos honduras donde el
presidente juan orlando hernández
felicitó a la izquierdista esposa del
depuesto presidente manuel zelaya
xiomara castró antes de que el consejo
nacional electoral anunciara los
resultados definitivos de los comicios
presidenciales
también la felicito el candidato
oficialista nasry asfura
y en barbados le damos el adiós a la
reina isabel la isla caribeña abandonó a
la corona británica para convertirse en
república y al hacerlo juramento a su
primera presidenta y a la cantante
rihanna como su heroína nacional
y vamos de inmediato con nuestra
historia principal una multitud se
reunió en el zócalo de la ciudad de
mexico para escuchar el mensaje del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
al cumplirse tres años de su llegada al
poder es decir la mitad de su mandato el
presidente que llegó al cargo con la
promesa de reducir la desigualdad y
acabar con la corrupción recibió esta
fecha con cerca del 70 por ciento de
aprobación
amlo dirigió su mensaje a los seguidores
de su partido el movimiento de
regeneración nacional morena y no a los
críticos que resaltan que los problemas
de inseguridad y los económicos se
mantienen la fecha llega en medio de una
polarización cada vez más acentuada en
méxico elijo la propuesta de una
consulta revocatoria en su contra que él
mismo promueve revisemos los primeros
tres años de la gestión de andrés manuel
lópez obrador y sus pendientes en el
siguiente informe que preparamos desde
la redacción para ustedes
la tercera fue la vencida para andrés
manuel lópez obrador amlo llegó a la
presidencia de méxico el primero de
diciembre de 2018 tras otros dos
intentos fallidos a lo largo de 18 años
representando al partido de la
revolución democrática pr fue de la mano
de morena su propio movimiento de la que
llegó al palacio nacional sus promesas
de acabar con la desigualdad y la
corrupción fueron clave para conseguirlo
con los anuncios hechos en el marco del
aniversario de su llegada al poder
aumentar la pensión a 9 millones de
adultos mayores así como a niños con
discapacidad y los montos de las becas
estudiantiles sigue dando pasos firmes
hacia ese objetivo pero para analistas
los cambios tienen un costo son cambios
importantes pero yo creo que lo que hay
que subrayar para el auditorio es el
compa en cambio de percepción de este
gobierno es un gobierno
divide al país o lo quieres mucho al
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador o
lo odio la inseguridad sigue siendo un
desafío que amlo no ha conseguido
abordar con éxito este sexenio que
apenas va en la mitad ya registra dos
tercios de los homicidios que los
registrados en el de su antecesor
enrique peña nieto en los seis años de
peña se registraron 156 mil 437
homicidios para septiembre de este año
te hacen registrado 100 mil 300 am lo
defendió el despliegue de 80.000
efectivos del ejército para combatir la
inseguridad de 30 mil más dedicados a
impedir que las caravanas de migrantes
lleguen a eeuu las fuerzas armadas
surgen del pueblo los soldados son
pueblos
uniformados
en materia económica lópez obrador tiene
por celebrar que su gobierno no se
endeudó durante la pandemia así como la
firma del renovado tratado de libre
comercio con canadá y eeuu en medio de
este panorama lópez obrador promueve una
revocatoria para que los ciudadanos
decidan en las urnas y termina su
mandato antes de 2024 la oposición
crítica que está haciendo una campaña
irregular porque está promoviendo la
ratificación de su mandato
gobernante no está a la altura de las
circunstancias
y no
manda obedeciendo al pueblo
revocación del mandato y para afuera
amlo continuará trabajando para
concretar al menos tres reformas
constitucionales que le permitan
consolidar su cuarta transformación
en honduras el presidente juan orlando
hernández felicitó a xiomara castró por
su victoria en los comicios
presidenciales del 26 de noviembre aún
cuando el consejo nacional electoral el
único organismo autorizado para dar los
resultados definitivos no los había
entregado lo mismo hizo el candidato
oficialista nasry asfura castró es la
esposa del depuesto presidente manuel
zelaya y marca el regreso de la
izquierda al poder en el país azotado
por la corrupción los vínculos de sus
gobernantes con el narcotráfico y una
pobreza que alcanza más del 70% de la
población
castró sería la primera presidenta en la
historia hondureña veamos el perfil en
el informe de luís muñoz
xiomara castró era una primera dama más
pero el golpe de estado de militares y
empresarios hondureños en 2009 contra su
marido y presidente manuel zelaya la
llevaron a un primer plano
obediencia cambiarme
en su tercer intento de lograr la
presidencia se ha alejado de su marido y
ha utilizado como una de sus bazas de
campaña ser la primera mujer presidenta
en la historia de honduras un país
tradicionalmente machista y conservador
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en este sentido prometió aprobar el
aborto en tres causales y ampliar
derechos para el colectivo lgtb como el
matrimonio igualitario
además promete un cambio político
después de 12 años de gobiernos
conservadores salpicados por casos de
corrupción y lazos con el narcotráfico
su promesa de construir un estado
socialista y democrático ha generado
virulentas críticas de la oposición que
vaticinan que honduras va a ser una
nueva cuba o venezuela
temores en un país que igual que el
resto de la región sufre de poca cultura
política y suelen aflorar autoritarismos
personalistas por lo que un fracaso en
el reformismo podría acabar con las
esperanzas de su promesa de una honduras
libre soberana e independiente
y en venezuela el tribunal supremo de
justicia ordenó repetir las elecciones a
gobernador en barinas el estado natal de
hugo chávez en una decisión calificada
de golpe por parte de la oposición lo
que sucedió es lo siguiente el
representante de la opositora mesa de la
unidad democrática se impuso por un
estrecho margen al candidato oficialista
y actual gobernador argenis chávez el
hermano de hugo chávez fue entonces
cuando un disidente de la oposición
llamado adolfo superlano presentó una
demanda argumentando que el candidato
freddy superlano estaba inhabilitado
para ocupar cargos públicos
demanda que la máxima corte aceptó pero
ya freddy superlano había sido indultado
por nicolás maduro y en argentina se
cumplieron 20 años del corralito una
medida del entonces presidente fernando
de la rúa con la que restringió la libre
disposición del efectivo de los
argentinos para evitar una fuga de
capitales y un colapso económico causado
por la decisión de mantener el valor de
un peso a un dólar repasemos la historia
en el informe de andrés dulce
hemos tenido que adoptar una medida
transitoria de limitación a la
extracción de dinero en efectivo
y sólo se podrá hacer durante este
periodo de 90 días por cifras de 250
pesos semanales con este anuncio el
entonces ministro de economía daba a
conocer una medida que 20 años después
sigue retumbando en la memoria colectiva
de los argentinos el corralito una serie
de políticas monetarias que buscaban
frenar una de las peores crisis
económicas del país en décadas dirigidas
a restringir el retiro de dinero de los
bancos y prohibir las transferencias
monetarias al exterior aunque las
transacciones electrónicas estaban
permitidas en ese momento sólo el 1 por
ciento de las personas usaban tarjetas
débito o de crédito tras el anuncio de
las medidas el 1° de diciembre y la
entrada de vigor el 3 hubo caos en las
sedes bancarias lo que ocasionó masivas
protestas que derivaron en violencia y
saqueos
la atención alcanzó su máximo el 19 de
diciembre cuando el entonces presidente
fernando de la rúa anunció por
televisión el estado de sitio
así como enfrente los problemas
económicos así como dispuse medidas de
emergencia para asistir a los más
necesitados
decidí poner límites a los violentos que
se aprovechan de las penurias ajenas por
eso y según las atribuciones que la
constitución nacional me confiere como
presidente de la nación es declarado el
estado de sitio en todo el territorio
nacional para asegurar la ley y el orden
en el país y terminar con los incidentes
de las últimas horas las fuerzas de
seguridad respondieron con violencia
entre el 19 y el 20 de diciembre
murieron 39 personas en las
manifestaciones
horas después se vería una de las
imágenes más icónicas de la crisis el
presidente de mi tía y dejaba la casa
rosada en helicóptero tras la renuncia
de de la rúa se crearía una crisis
política e institucional que llevaría al
nombramiento de cuatro presidentes en
menos de dos semanas
20 años después el panorama sigue siendo
desolador con una inflación galopante y
una difícil relación con el fondo
monetario internacional
barbados cortó sus lazos con el reino
unido- y se convirtió así en la
república más joven del mundo ya no
tendrá como jefa de estado a la reina
isabel segunda la isla del caribe marcó
la ocasión con una ceremonia a la que
paradójicamente asistió el heredero de
la corona británica el príncipe carlos
que condenó la atrocidad del comercio de
esclavos vivido en la isla que fue el
centro de dicha práctica se trata de la
declaración más fuerte de condena desde
la corona pero está muy lejos del perdón
que se exigía desde la isla barbados es
el cuarto país que reemplaza a la reina
por un presidente pero seguirá haciendo
parte de la commonwealth la organización
de 54 antiguos territorios británicos
que mantienen vínculos de cooperación
barbados se deshizo de sus últimos
vínculos con la monarquía británica casi
400 años después de que los barcos
ingleses atacaran por primera vez
y yo sandra por un ela manso no juro que
serviré con bien y verdad a barbados en
el cargo de presidente con la ayuda de
dios
la jefe del estado más nuevo del mundo
hizo un llamado a la unión recordando a
todos que el futuro de su país está en
sus manos
miriam somos barbadenses nosotros el
pueblo debemos darle a la república de
barbados su espíritu y su sustancia
nosotros el pueblo somos barbados vidas
entre los invitados rihanna declarada
heroína nacional
y un invitado más controvertido el
heredero británico al trono muchos han
criticado la decisión de invitar al
príncipe carlos a un miembro de la
familia real pero él insistió en la
amistad del reino unido con barbados y
reconoció su horrible legado colonial
desde los días más oscuros de nuestro
pasado y la espantosa atrocidad de la
esclavitud que mancha para siempre
nuestra historia la gente de esta isla
forjó su camino con extraordinaria
fortaleza
barbados fue epicentro de la trata
transatlántica de esclavos durante más
de un siglo la población actual es
mayoritariamente afrodescendiente al
separarse de la monarquía barbados se
espera distanciarse de su pasado
colonial pero el futuro depara grandes
desafíos para la nueva república la
inflación ha elevado los precios y el
kobe 19 ha golpeado la industria
turística de la isla que apenas está
comenzando a recuperarse
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa para más información de
nuestro continente pueden seguirme en
redes sociales en la dirección que ven
en sus pantallas y seguir viendo
france24
[Música]
france24 habla con